how did you know this story was special
or or maybe didn't you didn't yeah we
felt we felt was special because we we
felt special I guess yes because we I
don't know because when you write a
screenplay I think you think it's
special you know whether or not it is
special is sort of up to the you know
the heads of the future but we thought
it was special I guess I thought it was
special because we enjoyed writing with
each other and we enjoyed the story that
we had built and we had some good plot
twists and we liked the nonlinear
structure and we had written you know he
he jason had written four or five or six
screenplays at that point and I had
written two and so when you get to your
third script your third feature script
you've learned you trust me you've
learned a lot and and and I think us
teaming up his weaknesses and strengths
and my weaknesses and strengths really
were were were worked well together he's
very good at things that I'm not and
vice versa and so we liked it and we
gave it to ten of our friends here's
something that I would advise any
screenwriter to do he's starting out you
have a screenplay don't send the PDF to
a person and ask him to read it it's
just you're never gonna get anything
like that what you have to do is you
have to make it a special thing you have
to say what we did was we took ten
friends some in the industry some not in
the industry we'd know many people in
the industry but you know friends who we
trusted him thought they were smart and
we said we have a hard copy of the
screenplay we'd like you to come over to
we had an office that he wouldn't let my
co-writers working for someone in office
in Manhattan
we would like you come over the office
if you wouldn't mind we're not gonna
stand over you like you know a funny
farm and you know watch you read the
pages or whatever but we'd like you to
read it and we'll walk away we'll be
gone for a couple hours you can write
notes whatever you can bash it we don't
care we just want like ten different
people's point of view so that's what we
did we we had ten people read it like
they couldn't leave with it they
couldn't take it we didn't you know that
way we know they're gonna read it you
know and and we're not gonna stand over
their shoulder we like left the office
came back and then we sit down with them
and we just talk it out with them we
took all their notes we decided what we
what we were feeling and and we're the
sort of the consensus notes were and
then we went right back into it and and
two weeks later we had like a script
that we were able to we felt could
perhaps be given to people to of note so
you felt in giving a PDF that it would
just sit in someone's inbox and they
would maybe find a reason to say I'm you
know what I'm so sorry I'm really busy
but by having them there sitting them
down you know with uninterrupted time it
was just a better way it's I mean it's
listen that's a fact I mean think about
it
in terms of being on the other side of
the coin if your friend sends a PDF a
hundred page PDF of you of something and
maybe by the way you're not a
screenwriter you're like their friend
and you don't really read screenplays a
lot it's a seam it's it's a daunting
task it's a task that you know I don't
explain it you could be excited about
reading a screenplay that comes in to
your inbox but generally speaking in the
age we live in with emails and social
media and all these things going on for
people to get distracted by to read your
friend or your cousin's your second
cousin your friends brothers uncle
screenplay or whatever you know we felt
that no one's gonna read our script if
we just send them a PDF of it we felt
let's just set a time from the read it
like be huh not be in the room when they
read it but that way they'll read it and
then right after they read it we get
their fresh unfiltered you know like
feelings about the screenplay and then
if we see things from like that if six
out of the ten of them are saying this
is no good well then you know we know
that's something we got to work on
you